thank you for the invitation to this
workshop so I just continue where
Michael stopped so I would just want to
point out first of all that he left this
question open
so whether standard I mean the standard
definition of hitting set for VP bar the
verification problem of that right so
you get a set and you want to certify or
you want to verify whether it hits VP
bar and that verification you want to do
in peace peace so the best that is known
currently or before ever the best that
was known was verification can be done
in exponential space so one corollary of
our work would be that this can now be
there in peace peace so without the
robust thing so just getting set for VP
bar certification we see is now possible
in peace tools but since this is a DCT
crowd I should rephrase some of the main
results as so in geometric terms upfront
without going into my polynomial
notation so so you can keep this setting
in mind there is the space F to the end
F is a field and we want it to be a J
Brickley closed because of because we
want to use algebraic geometry but we
won't need any assumptions on the
characteristic so characteristic can be
P equal to 2 or it can be 0 whatever so
so suppose you are given a map from this
space to itself
let's let's try
so suppose you are given a polynomial
map from the space F to the end to
itself right so this is given via n
polynomials so these are n very 8 n
polynomials so on any point alpha bar
what it is doing is it is computing the
coordinates F 1 at alpha bar F 2 at l4
what what - it tells over so you get
another point in the same space so keep
this think of this as the input you are
given if Phi's so so you are given this
you are given this polynomial map the
definition is given to you in the input
and that you can see as defining this
this action and we want to study the
properties of image of this map so we
will be interested in two problems first
are you call algebraic dependence
problem so this is so you look at the
image of F look at its
zariski closure which thankfully I will
need to define here everybody knows what
this is so what is the dimension of this
is it less than n so this is so the
first point is that although you already
know what is the definition of closure
it may not be immediately clear that
here the closure is actually a variety
okay in general for an arbitrary set
when you close it you may not get a
variety because it may decompose in two
varieties it made it so it may be
decomposable it may not be reducible but
here since you are looking at the image
of a polynomial map you can actually
prove as a homework exercise that the
closure is a variety okay so is the
dimension of this variety N or smaller
than n so you want to distinguish
between the two
[Music]
exactly whether there is an Annihilator
so this is the question of algebraic
dependence so they're these polynomials
are dependent or not so when the
dimension is less than n they are
dependent otherwise they are independent
okay so you want to distinguish between
these two things but here is the
geometric meaning of that second
question I call zero enclosure which has
the name only suggest you want to check
whether zero is contained here so the
point 0 whether it is contained in in
this variety so so this is the question
which I mean it's a very it may not be
clear at this point but it's a very very
expressive problem and it can actually
capture any problem of interest in
approximative complexity in particular
you have seen null cone problem in this
workshop you saw this question of
verification of a heading set for VP bar
all these questions very easily in a
standard way will reduce to this so this
so this is the problem of zc4 us and
what we actually do is behave our pspace
algorithm for this and this will be the
method will be completely characteristic
independent so ok what what do we show
for these two questions no so the first
question is much much easier so what we
show is that this this is an AM
intersection coil so these these are
reserved main results so the question of
algebraic dependence will show that it
is an AM intersection Co M so in
particular it could not be np-hard in
fact if you were working over complex
there is a randomized Paloma time
algorithm so over complex and
sufficiently large characteristic this
is actually practically a solved problem
but for low characteristic it is still
open and we showed that I mean it wasn't
even known whether it is in the follow
meal hierarchy this work shows that it's
in came intersection Co here for this we
show P space
the best the previous best was xpx space
especially for finite teams or final
characteristic there was nothing better
than X base node and right so this so in
the future we would like to show this to
be in VPP so a practical algorithm for
this and we would learn so ask Ethan has
challenged us this needs to be put in a
pH and the challenge is interesting
because he says that if we put it in pH
then we will get an alternative for GCT
so with that qualifier it becomes an
interesting question make sure the first
result is not under erh and when the
strengthening that we are asking for
under the second for a second no no
there is no grh forget about gr it so
everything here is unconditional and
mathematical boost right so so these
problems these other problems like
verification of hitting set for VP bar
or the question of null cone problem
these are all very special cases of jet
C in fact as we pointed out the malecon
problem is expected to be an NP
intersection Co MP this problem is not
this problem actually has a again as a
homemaker so exercise you can show that
this is np-hard so forth so this problem
the best you can hope is aim you cannot
get below NP okay so I will give a more
maybe a more explicit definition of this
this is the algebraic geometric
definition for zxe but there is a most
palatable definition so we see that in
the slides you see in fact two two ways
to define two more ways to define this
problem something happened right so the
first the the ad result is that ad is
not hard and the second GCT chasm is
filled by showing that
see is in pspace but it's a much more
general result than just filling the
cousin I think Azam deets preceding this
workshop so in this workshop it has been
redefined now so now the Tama is bring
it down to anything below peace peace
okay
okay so now let us go through these
things a bit more carefully so when we
have to stop so the question of
algebraic dependence testing is you are
given polynomial F 1 to F em they are n
varying over some field and we will call
them algebraically dependent if there is
a non zero in highlighted which means
that you substitute F 1 to F em in a and
you get zero so and it will not be very
important but you can assume the input
polynomials to be given by algebraic
circuits so in particular they may have
exponential degrees the maxim so once
you have this notion of dependence so
this is naturally generalizing the
notion of linear dependence right so you
are actually so we are actually trying
to generalize linear algebra to non
linear settings and you get a notion of
rank out of this so that is in the
literature it is called transient is
degree because it is something to do
with field extensions transcendental
field extensions so we continue with
this you can you could also call this
algebraic rank so for polynomials F 1 2
F M the algebraic rank or translate is
degree is the maximum number of
algebraically independent for normals in
the set so simple example is if you look
at x1 plus x2 and sum of squares
depending on what characteristic you are
in it is either either these two are
independent so the transient is degree
is 2 so this happens in all the cases
except when the characteristic is true
because
characteristic is true you can see that
the second one is square of the first so
in that case the transcends degree is 1
otherwise it is always 2 you can also it
is easy to show that this notion is
actually independent of algebraic field
extensions so you can go to algebraic
closure of the base field and still the
transcendence degree would not change it
is invariant up to algebraic extensions
so we can assume that F is f bar for
this talk and problem of ADF is defined
as given these polynomials in some form
test the algebraic dependence over this
field so you just have to answer yes or
no and the quantitative version will be
compute the cassaday's degree so it is
not really clear whether this problem is
computable just by the definition
because you don't really know how big
the Annihilator is right so this problem
could have been uncomputable as well but
it is not it is actually computable and
so then the questions which are open are
more to do with the computational
complexity of this problem no so the
Annihilator usually is very difficult ok
not follow me sighs yeah ok yeah so it
is a it is a Polaris but will it will
not change anything
I mean you could have I mean even if you
look at you think of it as our series I
think it will have the same
and so yeah so you can ask can is the
annihilator special and also in the next
slide we will see that actually there is
a classical degree bound for the
annihilator but we cannot say anything
more than that so it usually annihilator
is hard and there is a result by leaders
that it's even very simple questions
about the annihilators if you ask
they are like sharpie hard questions so
so this so what are the applications or
where does this concept appear so this
is fundamental in computer algebra and
also in algebra and geometry because
well as I have already defined ad in
that form it's it's a question about
dimension of that variety and in
computer science it was used to design
these algebraic pseudo-random objects
called extractors and so in fact that
that picture of polynomial map is from
basically inspired from this and then it
was used to prove lower bounds for
circuits and also to design hitting sets
in several works specifically the
concept of an highlighters has been used
recently it was already there in hinds
and snore and then recently it has been
used to prove bootstrapping of variables
results for hitting sets and so this
work gives another application of an
highlighters which will be to solve the
question of Z see also there actually we
will work with an highlighters and try
to find properties of it which will be
equivalent to Z see so so we will see
that actually the question of Z see is
related to polynomial system solving and
it is also related to the questions in
GCD
any any questions at this point okay so
quickly go through the previous results
of this question of algebraic dependence
so it's a classical result and it's a
very it's a tight result that minimal
and high later has has degree at most
product of the degrees of the polynomial
so in high letters may be infinitely
many so depending on how small the
dimension of this variety is I mean as
long if it is n minus 1 then there is
minimal is unique because the N
highlighting ideal is principal but as
soon as you go to n minus 2 dimension it
becomes crazy so you can read this as
saying there is at least one and high
later what in the first case so the when
the dimension is less than n there is at
least one and high later with degree
product of degrees of the input and it's
tight and so what so that bound is
simply a it's an exponential bound
it's simply exponential and it is a
singly exponential and since the number
of polynomials is only M the number of
coefficients or the number of monomials
in this and high later they are only
exponentially many it is they are single
exponentially many so so using this
actually you can set up a linear system
to basically you are trying to find the
coefficients the unknown coefficients of
the annihilators and this linear system
is exponentially large you can solve it
in piece piece so you so you have shown
that algebraic dependence problem or
irrespective of the field is in piece
piece
so this is the computational complexity
upper bound and so there were some
improvements on this known so if you
think of arithmetic or algebraic circuit
representation then think of the bit
size or the circuit also take into
account the big size so pi is not
written there be the big size not just
the size of the circuit but also what
are the constants if you want to do
explicit computation then you have to
look at bit size so below P space there
was a result it is not very important
what this is what it is just something
below P space not yet in polymer
hierarchy it's something between P space
and pH so the thing is that this result
does not need any restriction on the
field okay this is this is true in
general when you are when you look at
special fields so when the
characteristic is zero or it is
sufficiently large so large actually
just means larger than this pair abound
so as long as the characteristic is zero
or bigger than thorough bound then there
is a very nice classical criteria
criterion which is which is called
Jacobi's criterion so you look at this
Jacobean matrix which is just the first
order partial derivatives of your
polynomials so it's an N n cross M
matrix and so this is a symbolic matrix
the entries are polynomials so over the
function field whatever is the rank that
is equal to the translate degree okay so
the question reduces to just checking a
determinant of a symbolic matrix which
you can solve in randomized polynomial
time by fixing the variables
so where does it feel when the
characteristic is not zero so the
failure so that so actually it can be
shown is that the proof works as long as
this field extension is separable now
you don't know what is that just ignore
this statement but if you know what a
separable ax T then this criterion is
actually just dependent on separable ax
T of this field extension so when the
characteristic is zero or it is large
this extension is always a separable
without any assumptions then the
characteristic is too small then there
are bad cases when this could be
inseparable and then the third criterion
fields once it fails it is very hard to
find a different criteria I mean it so
it's always so it is still an open
question how to characterize algebraic
dependence or independence so separate
bility just means that these these
variables excise they have distinct
conjugates so when you look at this X I
over this field the conjugates in the
main poly they are distinct so as long
as that happens the criterion works and
there is a result that extends this
criterion to limited inseparability it's
not a general result but when the when
there is inseparability but it's only
constantly large in that case also there
is a smooth extension of the Yacoubian
criterion right so so when I say
constant inseparable degree then there
it is then it is polynomial it basically
reduces to linear algebra in some space
you have to make sure that space is not
large too not too large any other
questions
the middle Annihilator has a degree
that's equal to the product it's not
cleared I think for generic instances
that will be the case
okay so let me now move to the first
result which is that this question of ad
is in a so for that I will I will
rephrase which I'm kind of already done
I will rephrase this question of ad to
polynomial map and its entropy so
consider the map bold F from the space F
to the N to F to the M the N is the
number of so n was the number of
variables and M is the number of
polynomials given to you so from now on
I will assume that N and M are equal and
that the field is actually a GL field is
big enough so so so this these slides
will be interesting only in the case of
finite field because already for complex
or characteristic zero the problem is
simple the problem of ad is in B P P so
think of s as a finite field just big
enough yes but I do not want to make it
infinite because in the protocol in the
aim protocol I need a finite field so I
want to still keep it finite but big
enough so these assumptions see I don't
want to go into it it's again an
exercise to show that if you solve this
case you solve all the other cases so we
just take n to be M so what can we say
about the geometry or the entropy of the
map so the questions you can ask are of
this of the or of the following type
what is the dimension of the image and
what is the dimension of the preimage so
basically fix a point here and look at
the pre image what can you say about the
pre image of of a generic point here in
the image you can ask these questions
you can also ask the question about the
risky closure of the image which will be
the second question
and I just remark that these questions
seem unrelated to the ideal f12 FM so
you do the thing given to you in the
input is this set of polynomials but if
you look at the ideal and if you look at
the zeroes the variety that doesn't seem
to have any relationship with these
questions okay because you are not
looking at the zero set of F you are
actually looking at the image of f
closure so this is a completely
different object so our solutions are
the the ideas here will also be very
different we will not be looking at it's
a different variety it's not the variety
said if so so the entropy behavior here
should follow the following intuition
that when these polynomials are
independent then you would expect the
image to be large so the proof is by
example
they take F 1 to F m as x1 dot xn and in
that case the image is the whole space
so you you you generalize this and
imagine that okay in general also when
the polynomials are independent then
then this space will the image will
essentially be very close to the whole
space ok and when the polynomials are
dependent then the image will shrink so
this is the this is the basic intuition
and you and we basically formalize this
to get these two protocols so if we show
that ad has a protocol and we show that
compliment of ad also has a protocol
I'm not sure I think it's even simpler
by the way in general is the symbol it
comes home she'll Corp and I said what
do you mean they for the field of
complex or characteristic 0 it is equal
to in general sure so whatever is the
rank yeah that will is less than equal
to translators degree but it could also
be 0 because if you just simply look at
X to the P then the a Jacobian is
actually 0 okay yeah so the notation
that will be of help here is this Prima
general notation so you take a point B
which is which is in the image and look
at the pre image
so this F inverse B is a set so I call
that pre image and image is clear it is
just small F of this F to the n that
that steam
so the two sexes our image of f and you
let me call this e so you basically go
to go to the image of a and then look at
f inverse so this will be the pre image
so these are the two sets and basically
we'll show that in one case in one case
the image is bigger in other case pre
images speak and then the aim protocol
they just distinguish that yeah so the
thing is in this in these am protocols
you only need a doubling so as long as
the numbers are MA or whatever y + 2 y
you have a protocol but Y itself can be
exponential
my intuition is that like large means
something like 1 in the degree where the
degree can be exponential in the circuit
size and small would be something like
one in the size filters when you say
it's large it up no your feet size being
large enough so field size think of the
field sizes bigger than product of
degrees something like that or product
of degree whole square you know so his
question was about the field actually
how big should the field yeah so field
also will just be product of degree
whole square something like that yeah
right so the C the finite field is a
Galois field of size Q q is a prime
power so yeah so for something in the
image F inverse be the size of that set
will denote by begin B
right right so this this entropy is I
mean we basically I have rephrased this
question of transcendence degree ooh
entropy of this map so for the
polynomial map it is it is a
interpretation with entropy and or you
can also in this term it is it is
algebraic geometric so and the first
that the definition was completely
explicit that what is the max number of
algebraically independent columns there
are kind of three interpretations so
actually I don't want to get into the
proofs of this I just very quickly go
through this slide so there I want to
study the preimage so what is the
difference so suppose the polynomials
are algebraically independent right so
in this case so when the polymers are
exhibit ly independent you the intuition
is that image will be large and a
parallel intuition is that pre image
will be small okay so this is what the
lemma is seen that for algebraically
independent polynomials if you look at
the pre image of F of a so f of a is B
here and look at the pre image of that
then that is that is small there small
is with respect to this D product of
degree it is smaller than this for
almost all the points in the domain but
so how is this proved well this is
proved by looking at the relationships
between X I and on these polynomials so
in these polynomials are all independent
they can actually generate any variable
X I and when you look at the
relationship that has degree at most D
and using that you can get this result
using the fact that a degree D
polynomial has loaded it at intensity of
roots in the big space but I won't get
yes exactly yes but I won't I don't want
to go into this and it also actually
will imply that the image has geometric
dimension N and the premed has dimension
zero okay so the dimension of generic
preimage plus the dimension of image is
equal to n but it's extreme it's zero
and n we want to think of this
geometrically the other cases when the
polynomials are dependent so in this
case you would expect I mean you would
expect the preimage to be large and this
is what we are saying that for almost
all these for a high density of is the
preimage is is big so you fix here K to
be D or to D so then here you have the
preimage bigger than to D and there you
had preimage smaller than T so you have
a gap so this gap gives you a name
protocol yes approximately entropy of
the output in this a few years ago real
and solid but darn approximating the
entropy of polynomial maps for finite
fields having some of the protocols
actually in VPP summary statistic of
some of the lemmas here may give an
efficient I mean using sampling you can
implement them so to answer that I have
to read that people I
find the rag to be the rank of the
jacuzzi and then yeah so then it
completely fails them because here you
are doing algebra independence
interesting but there you say that
suppose you have a polynomial master the
Jacobian has larger Isis just given the
given the family of polynomial you just
ask what's the entropy of the output of
the image that's the question just
approximate the entropy of the oh yes so
it's a good point that these methods do
not depend on the characteristic and
also do not assume anything about the
Jacobian so even if the Ghia Cobian did
not exist they did not know about it
still all these things hold so this is
actually the point of the first result
because otherwise we have you have a
practical algorithm then the criterion
works like so then just using a standard
method on this set you have verified the
ID in and then and symmetrically now or
and obviously we look at the image no so
in the independent case you expect the
image to be large which means that for a
good fraction of the B's there should be
some pre image so this is just a
refreezing of that this again is a play
with with the annihilators and in the
dependent case the image should be small
so for most of the bees
there should be no pre image and now you
should look at image of f so if you if
you use so the am protocol will be
biased towards the case when the
polynomials are independent so ad bar
gets certified
in EM so it is in Korean okay so we have
shown that or this is our very
high-level sketch of a DS in the em
intersection Cohen any questions okay
so then let me proceed to the yeah and
in particular it will it rules out that
ad is np-hard because if it is np-hard
then the then pH will be Sigma - we
don't expect that unfortunately this
metal method does not give any any
algorithm at all
so algorithmically all these arguments
are useless
it's only a complexity evidence that the
problem is not np-hard but it does not
really give us any algorithm or any
heuristic to actually solve or to test
algebraic dependence so in any special
case okay so now I want to move to the
second problem so I'll present it in
three ways so so the first is is is this
where you are given polynomials you look
at the image of f and then close it and
the question is whether it contains you
so what is the meaning of closure
well the risky closure is basically you
so in general if you have if your set is
image of f so for a set s in the space s
bar is basically defined as look at all
the polynomials that vanish on s so the
set of those polynomials will form an
ideal and look at the 0 set of that
okay so so it is possible that sbar does
not increase it is equal to izz but
usually it will increase if you start
with an arbitrary set which is not a
zero set then it will it will increase
and these are you can also see this as a
limiting process so the limit points
have been included but this is of course
very algebraic I mean even to see that
this notion coincides with Michaels and
Roshan over complex or oval reals is a
non trivial exercise so but this is are
completely algebraic way to define
zariski closure without taking without
without invoking analysis or without
taking limits so we will continue with
this this I think just needs that F is
algebraically closed
moving interesting theorems so this is
also the smallest affine variety so it
becomes a variety because of because our
set is very special it is image of F so
in this case it is actually a variety in
general s Bar may not be a variety it
may decompose for example if you take s
to be two points and you try to close it
so then then obviously it will be
decomposable right but that will not
happen in this case because here you are
looking at image of a polynomial map
it's a interesting enough case that the
closure is a variety and it is a
smallest affine variety that contains
contains it yeah so this you can skip
this you already know so an interest and
illuminating example is if you look at
these two polynomials X 1 and X 1 X 2
minus 1 so in these the in the image of
this polynomial map you don't find 0
right because well 0 would mean that X 1
is equal to 0 but then if X 1 is 0 then
this evaluates to minus 1 so there is no
chance of 0 being in this in the image
but so what happens when you take the
closure so when you take the closure you
will be surprised to know that you get
to the whole space so in this case
actually the closure is is X square so
every point is actually a limit point
it's the point
though here is everything exactly yes
yes that is that this is exactly what
happens here which so these two are
independent so the so this actually you
can deduce from the definition so if if
the polynomials are independent then the
annihilating ideal is zero and the zero
set of zero is everything right so so in
this sense you already get in this
example you already get the insight that
we are strictly generalizing polynomial
system solving so you are you're given
polynomials if you wanted to find roots
that was the question of whether zero is
in the image if you look at now a
closure of the image that's a different
question it is not the question of
polynomial system solving but we will
see that in the we'll see later that
it's actually a natural extension of
polynomial system solving so how do you
solve this so sexy I mean you can try to
find this this I explicitly so you are
given polynomials you try finding
computing the annihilating ideal by
finding it's generators and everything
can be bad here the generators may be
exponentially many the degree the degree
and the complexity of the annihilators
could also be exponentially large and
things could even be doubly exponential
actually because you are using
elimination Theory here by or grosvenor
basis so so you actually can solve this
in X space which is doubly exponential
time and the annihilating ideal may be
terribly complicated which it is
actually most of the cases
generators of the education generator no
I don't think so I think here the
grosvenor basis will could kick in it
could be worse
so that was only talking about one and I
did so when the annihilating ideal is
principal then there it is fine of
course but when it is non principal it
could be very bad yeah but I have to
think about that maybe these results
imply something there
in general you cannot just buy grosvenor
basis you cannot reduce anything okay
second two minutes I thought you said
fight between well you have seen one
version so I guess others I can so
Annihilator at zero is is the question
whether every and highlighter of this
polynomial map vanishes at zero or the
constant term of every and highlighter
is zero and that question is actually
equivalent to Z see this this can be
seen easily let me skip it so this
Annihilator at zero question is also in
X place it's an equivalent question and
third more it the most interesting
interpretation of this is or equivalent
formulation of this question is is the
following which we call approximate
polynomial satisfiability so this is a
generalization of polynomial
satisfiability so here you don't warn
you are not looking for a root but you
are looking for these rational functions
in a single variable epsilon such that
when you evaluate fi at these points
betas at this point beta you don't care
about zero you just care about it being
a polynomial that is a multiple of
Epsilon
so you should think of this as mod
epsilon so you want rational functions
beta such that f I add beta is 0 mod
epsilon so it's a completely algebraic
question but the analysis is of course
the the motivation is of course from
real analysis so you should think of
epsilon as tending to 0 and in that case
it is like when you substitute you
evaluate F I yet beta it becomes
arbitrarily small while beta may become
arbitrarily large because beta may have
1 over Epsilon so so basically the betas
may extend to infinity but fi 8 beta may
tend to 0 so it should this problem
should actually be called the infinite
simile approximate polynomial
satisfiability because it is not just an
approximate root but it's a sequence of
infinite sequence of points where the
system is system evaluation is tending
to 0 ok arbitrarily close to 0 this
question is also equivalent to Z see and
this is not trivial something called the
lame cool dick tag result is is needed
for this I'll also skip this way to
complicate it
so this question is in X space and this
EPS is the question which we have put in
T space but there is no time for that so
let me just jump to
yes this in particular covers GCT chasm
because this VP bar hitting set
generator verification problem can be
reduced to APS and in fact anything to
do with the approximation can be or
approximate of complexity can be reduced
to so all those things are special cases
let me skip the proof so I can discuss
the idea of line so so in the end what
we did is algebraic dependence testing
we showed in a intersection Co a.m. what
is open is finding any sub exponential
time algorithm for this for say P equal
to 2 so everything is open their
approximate polynomial satisfiability we
show in P space and we want to bring it
down and Keaton's challenge is to bring
it in th right so this will give you an
alternative to GCD that it is serious
and yes of one natural instance which is
open for both the problems is look at
set of quadratic polynomials what to so
we don't know indeed neither do we know
EPS for this Thanks
[Applause]
no so we were interested in this this in
this problem and here F is given to us
in the input yeah in the heating set
generator question Oh
the verification question so in the
verification question somebody gives you
an arbitrary candidate set so there
again it's not in control for the
weather because even in the packet thing
he's still using a degree bound to solve
some of the uses new acquaintance just
for the the constant term being nonzero
so it's basically the same algorithm is
concerned in three the piece piece
algorithm but with an additional
constraint so even if they were thought
of you know like it's yeah because the
so not seen in this question you have to
go over all the annihilators and ensure
that the constant term is zero so for
such an eye raters where the constant
term is one or nonzero pair o bound may
not be applicable you don't know where
those and hydrators bad annihilators lie
no I guess what your thing is the number
of coefficients is exponential anyway I
think that this together
[Applause]